pharmaceutical companies recently began
spending more on Advertising oh
than they do on research and development
in 2020 the year of the great pandemic
Pfizer spent 12 billion dollars on
marketing compared to just nine billion
dollars on R D companies like ABV and
Johnson Johnson and Bayer and many other
Pharma companies posted similar numbers
now what does all this money buy you if
you turn on any cable or network News
Channel you know the answer to that
question it buys incessant
advertisements that air during every
commercial break although the networks
of course will never admit it it also
buys positive coverage after all if the
networks criticize big Pharma they stand
to lose millions in advertising dollars